and that brings me into another topic
that's really interesting which is the
whole gender debate now that's out there
and I'm a big believer in like hey
you're a grown adult again do what you
want live the life you want but we're
now in a place where you can't even say
basic facts like you to to that small
minority that's very loud again you
can't even say a man is a man
and a woman is a woman and they're
different
now it's like well anyone can be a woman
anyone can be a man these words don't
even have meaning anymore so somebody
like yourself in the space where you're
talking about men and women and dating
all this stuff
these people want to tear out the
foundation of that which is just that
men and women are different so what do
you say to people that just refuse to
acknowledge that a man is a man a woman
is a woman biologically they're
different well I use it they're male or
female
so I go with
male female after that you want to have
the construct of men and women fun
do you
you're talking about biologically
biological I'm gonna talk male female
and stuff like that after that people
are going to be like
foreign
why does it matter then but you realize
there's like 50 pronouns now like it's
like I don't I call you by your name
cool I call the person by name I'm not
gonna go out of my way to misgender the
person
[Music]
um
I'm gonna be able to find like a middle
ground when I respect the person and I
respect myself as well again it's not
because I disagree with you that I have
to disrespect you it's not because I
disagree with you that I have to call
you names and stuff like that okay not
that being that that being said
um
facts I will always go to the facts that
we know
okay find me something else that's going
to be able to change my facts then I'll
be like okay fine you got that but up to
now
and it's not everybody in let's not put
everybody in the same
uh in the same pot there's some people
that are that are trans and they're like
they understand
the way I understand it
but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go out
of my way to misgender people or
whatever will disrespect the person but
I don't have to agree right I don't have
to agree to to certain stuff now if that
if that that makes me this or that or
whatever that's debatable because I
value the person as they are nobody
should
have atrocities made to them
or being judged or being bullied or
anything like that but the facts Remain
the facts yeah according to the facts
that we have now that's where I'm at too
in a sense that I mean I don't care what
adults do with it like genuinely you
want to take hormones you know I don't
care if you want to call yourself a
polar bear I mean I don't care it
doesn't matter to me it's your life but
what I am worried about and what does
bother me is that now there are things
that are unique to say Womanhood like
women can have babies and women
get periods and women go through puberty
a certain way as a female and I don't
want those experiences taken away from
women or men that are unique to being a
man and a woman so you can call yourself
whatever you want you can do whatever
you want with your life but we should be
able to just acknowledge basic facts now
we're at a point where we can't even say
women get pregnant it's pregnant people
it's like hold up like guys can't get
pregnant you know what I'm saying like
I'm a female that was a proud moment for
me let me have it you know what I'm
saying so that's where I'm at with that
sometimes going with going with the
YouTube thing and everything is if you
learn to play by the rules you know
there's some words that you cannot say
and stuff like that you know you have to
go around you know yeah you know what I
mean
yeah
you know what I mean so there's always
things like that that you have to go
around I went through that because don't
even go there I know you know what I
mean that exactly you said what you said
you said you said what you said so we
we've been through it right so there's
some words that you cannot say there's
some things that you have to and you
always have to find a way to go around
them right in order to get the message
out there so that's why I use female and
male and female I don't say women's
sports I don't say male Sports I say
female sports male Sports yeah so what
are your thoughts on um the bathroom oh
girl I I forgot you was that she's sorry
I'm sorry but I wanted to know what are
your thoughts because I know you're kind
of like neutral you do what you want to
do but what are your thoughts when it
comes to the bathrooms
the bathrooms in a perfect world which
we don't live in in a perfect world
everybody should have a male a female
and ex bathroom okay
women don't women
I'm not ready
to take away the safety of women and I'm
talking about how they feel in certain
situations
because let's remember
feminism is about that that's what it
was right we want safety for women I
thought huh
that's not anymore that that's that's
what we're doing that's what we're
supposed to be that's what it was
supposed that's what it was supposed to
I'll go with that so I'm not ready to
sacrifice that for something else
so but I'm gonna try to find the
the the the compromise
so you want to have your bathroom that's
okay that's gonna be your bathroom yep
but they don't feel safe
I'm not ready to say [ __ ] it [ __ ] them
what
okay so you don't want us to say [ __ ]
them to you but you say [ __ ] them to
them right
you became the enemy you
know you became the same thing that you
were pointing the finger at so right you
need to have your bathroom you need to
you know you need to do your things and
there are some things that uh for
example trans people have that there's
something that's very specific to them
and and I do not want to deny that but
I'm not ready I don't know I don't want
to deny what's going on with women
either yes like the respect only goes
one way right and I do not want to deny
what's going on with man either that's
right
so
yeah if women don't feel safe in certain
situations I'm just gonna shut up
sometimes and sit down and say okay
what's the issue tell me what's going on
I don't know
but then again if man
tell me they don't feel safe in a
certain situations because it happens
because while we see men and like oh
yeah we're strong and we big and this
and that no when we're scared it's often
not physical
mm-hmm
it's it's we're going to lose careers
we're going to lose this we're gonna
lose that it's some I'm gonna shut up
and sit down and listen but this is the
this is the Crux of it because what
you're saying essentially comes back
down to men and women are different even
even the things we fear
guys aren't going to think about
physical safety in the same way that a
petite woman like I would it's just a
reality so you gotta deal in reality so
you can be respectful of everybody's
life choices as adults and be like do
what you want but reality still exists
so I'm I'm taking issue with the people
that want to toss out reality because
it's inconvenient for them if you want
to watch the full episode you're going
to click right here and if you want to
ask me a question one on one you want to
do a one-on-one FaceTime with a group of
your friends whatever you want you need
to download right now click right here
and let's get talking
foreign
[Music]